[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Serien guten Abend ihnen allen
Kristin selten war eine Grätsche so
wichtig später Pampel mehr von dir
Fußball Champions League die Bayern sind
weiter im Viertelfinale guten Abend dann
schauen wir jetzt gemeinsam auf unsere
Themen
Raketen gegen Zivilisten Russland
überzieht die Ukraine mit einer
Angriffswelle die Menschen tötet und die
Stromversorgung kommt
der nächste Anlauf schon lange gibt's
die elektronische Patientenakte nur hat
sie fast keiner Gesundheitsminister
Lauterbach will da jetzt Druck machen
und keine Angst vor Superstars die
Bayern werfen Paris Saint-Germain aus
der Champions League unter anderem mit
einem sehr langen Bein in höchstem
[Musik]
das ukrainische AKW saporicia bleibt
durch den Krieg ein schwelendes
Sicherheitsrisiko nach mehrstündigem
Stromausfall ausgelöst durch russischen
Beschuss ist es inzwischen wieder am
Stromnetz am Morgen schreckten überall
heulende luftsirenen die Menschen auf
mit mehr als 80 Raketen und Kamikaze
Drohnen Griff Russland an angeblich im
Visier militärische Einrichtungen und
infrastrukturziele die Attacken trafen
Regionen im gesamten Land die Hauptstadt
Kiew war ein Ziel außerdem steht er im
Süden Osten in der Mitte des Landes und
im Westen dort bei Lemberg beginnt der
Bericht von Jürgen Kehl
östlich von Lemberg etwa 100 km von der
polnischen Grenze entfernt ist der Krieg
für die Menschen in diesem Dorf
eigentlich weit weg doch im Morgengrauen
zerfetzt eine Rakete drei Häuser
Angehörige Nachbarn und ein paar Leute
vom Zivilschutz durchsuchen die
Einschlagstelle
sind unter den Trümmern sie haben sie
noch nicht gefunden wir hoffen sie leben
aber sie sind wohl nicht mehr am Leben
kurz darauf ist der letzte Funke
Hoffnung erloschen
das Dorf zählt fünf Tote
Rauch am Himmel über Kiew am Morgen
Flammen in einem Heizkraftwerk wieder
ein Angriff auf die Infrastruktur aber
auch Wohngebiete werden getroffen hier
sind die Schäden diesmal überschaubar
der Schrecken bei den Anwohnern aber
sitzt tief
die Fenster und balkonscheiben haben
gezittert beängstigend sehr beängstigend
das Kind bekam Angst und ist aus dem
Bett gesprungen
geht weil ein Meter weiter links oder
rechts und das hätte meine Wohnung sein
können ich habe keine Worte mehr
einen Rache Schlag mit Moskau die
Angriffe und zeigt diese Bilder eine
Antwort auf ukrainische Terrorakte
gemeint sind ungeklärte Übergriffe von
medizen auf russisches Gebiet vor einer
Woche die Rache trifft doch wieder die
Stromversorgung von Europas größtem
Atomkraftwerk saporicia die
nuklear-anlage ist Russisch besetzt und
wird von Ukrainern betrieben die Atom
auf sie ja alarmiert
das Atomkraft mit Notstrom
Dieselaggregaten das ist die letzte
Verteidigungslinie die letzte
Verteidigungslinie das passiert jetzt
zum sechsten Mal ich wiederhole zum
sechsten Mal
nach ein paar Stunden ist der Schaden
oder Stromleitung wieder behoben der
diesel-vorrat hätte für 10 Tage gereicht
Henna Hebestreit ist für uns in der
Ukraine wir hatten bisher immer Glück
aber das muss nicht immer so bleiben
sagte der Chef der Atomenergiebehörde
außerdem zum schwählenden
Sicherheitsrisiko in saporicia Hannah
wie sehen die Ukraine diese Situation
übertragenen Sinne rund um das
Atomkraftwerk noch nicht wir hatten
gerade noch Kontakt mit der
Regionalverwaltung von SAP und dann sagt
man uns die Anlage setzt zum Teil wieder
an der Stromnetz angeschlossen ohne die
Diesel Aggregate geht es noch nicht äh
ihr ja general Direktor grossi hat es ja
schon gesagt das ist die letzte
Verteidigungsanlage für einer Art
Super-GAU und er hat die internationale
Gemeinschaft auch dazu aufgerufen
endlich tätig zu werden die Situation
rund um das Atomkraftwerke und auch die
vielen Angriffe die wir heute hier in
der Ukraine auch hier in die miterlebt
haben haben die Menschen hier noch mal
ganz klar gemacht dass man sich
eigentlich nirgends in der Ukraine ganz
sicher sein kann hier nicht doch
irgendwie von den Auswirkungen des
Krieges getroffen zu werden vielen Dank
nach dem Brot das war Henna ihre Streit
wir machen jetzt mit einem ganz anderen
Thema weiter große Teile unseres Lebens
die verlagern sich seit vielen Jahren
immer mehr ins digitale und eigentlich
so der ursprüngliche Plan sollte dazu
auch längst ihre komplette medizinische
Lebensgeschichte gehören mit der
elektronischen Patientenakte darin
gebündelt alle Infos etwa über
Medikamente Operationen oder aber auch
über Impfungen seit zwei Jahren gibt sie
zwar schon wird aber nicht mal von einem
Prozent der gesetzlich Versicherten
genutzt der Gesundheitsminister
Lauterbach will das jetzt ändern wer
nicht ausdrücklich ablehnt bekäme sie
künftig automatisch noch sind aber
ziemlich viele Fragen offen etwa beim
Datenschutz Christiane hübscher
berichtet
Röntgenbilder Arztbriefe Testergebnisse
eine riesige Zettelwirtschaft sammelt
sich da an in einem einzigen Patienten
Leben all diese Daten stattdessen
gebündelt in einer App der Krankenkassen
das ist die Idee der elektronischen
Patientenakte kurz epapa mit der Ehepaar
erhalten wir nun endlich einen Platz wo
alle persönlichen Gesundheitsdaten ein
Zuhause finden der Vorteil jeder Arzt
kann sofort die medizinische
Vorgeschichte eines Patienten sehen
Nachteil noch immer nutzt so gut wie
niemand die Ehepaar der das
Gesundheitsminister will nun endlich den
Durchbruch für dieses 20 Jahre alte
politische Projekt schaffen mit mehr
Druck das Ziel 80 Prozent der gesetzlich
Versicherten sollen bis 2025 eine
elektronische Patientenakte haben und
wer nicht aktiv widerspricht stimmt
automatisch zu man muss sich nicht
kompliziert entscheidend für die Ehepaar
sondern wenn man nichts unternimmt dann
ist man trotzdem Ehepaar Träger und dann
kann in diese EPA auch eingesperrt
werden
patientenschützer aber kritisieren diese
Widerspruchslösung sei gerade bei
sensiblen Gesundheitsdaten rechtlich
nicht haltbar Herr Lauterbach irrt
sowohl bei den patientenrechten als auch
beim Datenschutz gilt wer schweigt
stimmt nicht zu der Wissenschaftler der
heute an Lauterbach Seite sitzt warnt
ohne digitales Daten sammeln verliere
Deutschland in der Forschung weiter den
Anschluss die größte
entdeckungsmaschine der Biomedizin
zurzeit sind Kandidaten was wir heute
machen um neue Zusammenhänge zu
entdecken ist wir graben in Daten und
das machen wir häufig in amerikanischen
Datensätzen weil die dort zur Verfügung
stehen und israelischen und nicht in
unserem eigenen Land viele Praktika
fürchten aber auch die elektronische
Patientenakte sorge für noch mehr
Schreibarbeit zu dem schlecht bezahlt
für die Ärzteschaft ist es sehr
unattraktiv weil die Vergütung extrem
niedrig ist eine oder 67 für das
Befüllen bzw weiterführende
elektronischen Patientenakte ist kein
Anreiz Deutschlands Gesundheitssystem
soll endlich voll digital werden doch
der Widerstand bleibt groß
wenn Millionen Briefe und Pakete
zwischenzeitlich nicht ankommen das
kennen viele in Deutschland noch von den
Warnstreiks im Januar und Februar jetzt
könnte es bald zu einem unbefristeten
Streik der Beschäftigten kommen weil
sich eine große Mehrheit bei einer
Urabstimmung gegen das Angebot der
Deutschen Post ausgesprochen hat
allerdings wird morgen noch mal weiter
verhandelt Ausgang ist offen mehr von
Ariane Güdel
noch sind sie täglich unterwegs die
brief- und Paketzusteller der Deutschen
Post wie hier in Duisburg aber das
könnte sich schnell ändern denn 85% der
Verdi Mitglieder haben sich in einer
Urabstimmung für einen unbefristeten
Streik ausgesprochen sollte die Post
ihren Lohnforderungen von 15% nicht nach
oder zumindest weiter Entgegenkommen nun
soll es neue Gespräche geben ich denke
der Druck ist jetzt ausreichend hoch und
deswegen hat die Post AG uns wieder
aufgefordert weil sie den Streik
Abbinden wollen das ist auch richtig so
wir streiten ja auch nicht einfach nur
so aus Vergnügen wir wollen ein gutes
Tarifergebnis und nicht einen langen
Arbeitskampf Streik und erst recht ein
unbefristeter ist teuer auch für ein
Unternehmen das heute in seiner
Bilanzpressekonferenz Rekord umsetze und
gewinne präsentierte
wir hatten einen sehr gutes 2022 ohne
Zweifel wir haben das beste EBIT dass
wir jemals hatten erzählt das zeigt dass
es Unternehmen in einer sehr guten
Verfassung ist der Gewinn vor Steuern
wuchs auf 8,4 Milliarden Euro an ein
Plus von 5,7 Prozent die Dividende wird
erhöht auf 1,85 € pro Aktie trotz guter
Bilanz lehnt die Post die Forderungen
von Verdi bisher als wirtschaftlich
nicht tragbar ab zu hoch da gehen die
Meinungen auseinander ich bin 15 % voll
lange schon ganz schön viel ich hätte
auch gern 15% mehr ich hätte auch die
10% gerne mehr heutigen Zeit wo alles
teuer ist muss man natürlich gucken wo
man bleibt schon ab morgen wollen Post
und Verdi zurück an den
Verhandlungstisch
Kohle hat während der Energiekrise
wieder an Bedeutung gewonnen ein Drittel
des deutschen Stromes stammte 2022 aus
Kohlekraftwerken das zeigen Zahlen des
Statistischen Bundesamtes demnach stieg
der kohleanteil im vergangenen Jahr um
8,4 %. ein Grund die starken Rückgänge
der Stromerzeugung aus Erdgas und
Kernenergie zweitwichtigste Stromquelle
war die Windkraft ihr Anteil wuchs um
9,4%
ja gut dreieinhalb Wochen ist die
Wiederholung der Berlinwahl jetzt her
heute haben CDU und
spd-koalitionsverhandlungen eingeläutet
dabei traf sich erstmal das Verhandler
Kernteam rund um die Partei
Landesvorsitzenden Kai Wegner und
Franziska Giffey ab nächster Woche
sollen sich 13 Arbeitsgruppen regelmäßig
austauschen Anfang April soll der
Koalitionsvertrag vorliegen wird man
sich einig dann könnte Kai Wegner das
Rote Rathaus übernehmen
und jetzt nach Brüssel und dem schier
endlosen Ringen um eine gemeinsame
Asylpolitik schon 2020 hatte die
EU-Kommission den sogenannten
migrationspakt vorgeschlagen viele
Einzelmaßnahmen die das europäische
Asylsystem reformieren sollen passiert
ist so gut wie nichts einige EU-Staaten
blockieren das vorhabener Krüger über
das Treffen der Innenminister heute und
über die Ereignisse auf der
Mittelmeerinsel Lampedusa
Kinder zuerst rufen die Retter der
Küstenwache
Frage hat sie forza Italien zählt den 24
Stunden
1350 neue Flüchtlinge nichts macht
deutlicher die EU braucht eine
gemeinsame asyl- und Migrationspolitik
die Innenminister haben das auf dem
Zettel aber wenn darauf auch das Wort
flüchtlingsverteilung steht dann so wird
die deutsche Ministerin sehen hakt es
der Kollege aus Frankreich etwa will den
migrationspakt auf Schnüren
Verantwortung zu Hause und Solidarität
mit anderen trennen
den Prinzipien Reitern sage ich die
Strategie des Alles oder Nichts führt
nicht weit der Pakt hat viele gute Texte
aber er ist seit Jahren blockiert
ob im kleinen oder im großen Ganzen die
Minister müssen sich schnell mit
Parlament und Kommission einigen denn
mit der Europawahl nächstes Jahr wäre
die Gesetzesarbeit und sonst gewesen
mein Eindruck war schon das Solidarität
und Verantwortung gemeinsam gedacht wird
und dass wir es alle auch als
historisches Momentum sehen dass aber
jetzt wo wir sehr viel Belastung haben
die Zeit ist gemeinsam voranzukommen um
gemeinsam zu ordnen und zu steuern doch
Ergebnisse gar eine gemeinsame
Verhandlungsposition gab es auch heute
nicht manche wollen darum auf den Pakt
nicht mehr warten probiers geduldig
Taten sind gefordert und daher beraten
wir heute und werden wir sehr intensiv
darüber beraten wie wir uns technisch
verbessern an den Außengrenzen aber wir
wie wir auch rechtlich neue Möglichkeit
schaffen dass wir schneller zurückweisen
können fraglich ob dadurch weniger die
Überfahrt Wagen gestern starben dabei
wieder 14 Menschen
in Israel haben erneut tausende Menschen
in zahlreichen Städten gegen die
geplante Justizreform der
rechtsreligiösen Regierung protestiert
in Tel Aviv blockierten sie eine
Schnellstraße und die Zufahrten zum
Flughafen damit wollten sie
Ministerpräsident netanjah an der
Abreise nach Italien hinter die
umstrittene Reform könnte schon im April
abgesegnet werden demnach soll es den
Parlament möglich sein mit einfacher
Mehrheit Entscheidungen des höchsten
Gerichtes aufzuheben
und in Georgien haben tagelange
Massenproteste Wirkung gezeigt die
Regierung zieht das geplante
agentengesetz jetzt doch zurück wegen
der Zitat Spaltung in der Gesellschaft
die der Entwurf ausgelöst hatte das
Misstrauen in der Bevölkerung ist aber
nach wie vor groß und so zogen am Abend
wieder tausende vor das Parlament sie
befürchten dass das Gesetz doch noch in
Kraft treten könnte und die Regierung
über Umwege die Pressefreiheit und
Zivilgesellschaft unterdrücken will
ähnlich wie in Russland
die katholische Kirche in Deutschland
hat nach tausenden Missbrauchsfällen mit
dem Synodalen Weg ein großes
Reformprojekt angeschoben geistliche und
Laien beraten in Frankfurt jetzt zum
vorerst letzten Mal über neue Wege aus
der Krise der Vatikan ist äußerst
skeptisch weil Jahrhunderte alte Rituale
und Regeln auf dem Prüfstand stehen es
geht um den Umgang mit Macht die Rolle
der Frau oder auch um die katholische
Sexualmoral Inken Klinge
gleich
bereste treffen das Reformprozesses der
katholischen Kirche synodaler Weg
beginnt noch einmal klar worum es Ihnen
geht sie sehen hier wie viele Vertrauen
hier sind und dass sie stehen ja für
Tausende von Frauen aber Tausende in
Deutschland und der ganzen Welt das ist
jetzt endlich Veränderungen geben muss
der wichtigste Punkt ist dass wir die
wir für eine Veränderung der Kirche
wollen dranbleiben dass wir nicht
aufgeben keine faulen Kompromisse machen
oder gar einknicken einknicken könnten
möglicherweise einige der Bischöfe
nachdem aus Rom zum wiederholten Male
ein klares Nein zu zentralen
Reformvorhaben kam die Stimmung ist
angespannt einzelne sind nicht mehr
angereist der Vorsitzende der
Bischofskonferenz macht den Anwesenden
Mut
wir sind uns bewusst dass uns allen viel
abverlangt wird einen gemeinsamen
Synodalen Weg zu finden wir wollen sie
aber von Herzen dazu einladen gehen Sie
den Weg auf dieser Zielgerade mit lassen
Sie sich nicht frustrieren resignieren
sie nicht ein Text der den Papst um die
Prüfung des Pflicht zu libats bittet ist
gerade eben mit großer Mehrheit
beschlossen worden schwieriger könnte es
bei den Themen Priesteramt für Frauen
oder Segnung homosexueller Paare werden
die Bischöfe müssen den Spagat
hinbekommen zwischen einerseits dem
Reform Wünschen der Mehrheit der
Gläubigen und den Bedenken aus Rom das
wird ohne Kompromisse nicht gehen ohne
Reformen aber wird die katholische
Kirche in Deutschland weiter an
Vertrauen und Bedeutung verlieren bis
Samstag wird diskutiert und abgestimmt
und für die meisten hier ist klar der
Synodale Weg darf auf den letzten Metern
nicht scheitern
sie kämpfte mit den Geschwistern Scholl
gegen die Nationalsozialisten traute die
letzte Überlebende der Widerstandsgruppe
weiße Rose ist jetzt im Alter von 103
Jahren in den USA gestorben la France
war 1941 als Junge Medizinstudentin von
Hamburg an die Uni München gewechselt
dort lernte sie Hans und Sophie Scholl
kennen 1943 wurde Lafrenz verhaftet nach
der Befreiung durch US-Soldaten wanderte
sie in die USA aus
und wir sind jetzt beim Sport und bei
erfolgreichen Biathleten Christin bei
-10 Grad echt frostig und dennoch
verheißungsvolle Auftakt beim Weltcup in
Österreich Schweden in den einzelnen
nach dem dritten Platz von Denise
Herrmann Wick konnte
den ersten Sieg der deutschen Männer
seit fast einem Jahr verboten
Benedikt doll wirkt heute wie
ausgewechselt selbstbewusstes schnelles
schießen auch beim letzten Anschlag 5
Treffer insgesamt also 20 der Lohn der
erste Saison Sieg in diesem Winter für
doll dahinter der Italiener Tomaso
giacomel und 3 Christiansen aus Norwegen
bei den Frauen ebenfalls eine gute
Mannschaftsleistung Denise Hermann Wick
Stich dabei heraus trotz einer
strafminute-platz 3 für die Einzel
Olympiasiegerin es gewinnt Dorothea
Wierer aus Italien ihre Landsfrau Lisa
wie trotz sie sich hat sich als zweite
die kleine Kugel in der
Disziplinenwertung
der FC Bayern München steht im
Viertelfinale der Champions League und
beschert Paris St Germain mit Messi und
Papi das Turnier aus nach dem 1:0 im
Hinspiel gelangt ein zwei zu null vor
eigener Kulisse clever herausgespielt
eine Grätsche wie gemalt Bayerns
abwehrkünstler Matheis Delikt in einer
Schlüsselszene des Spiels Top 9 von 10
Verteidigern hören da aufzulaufen weil
sie sagen der See drin und er liebt halt
zu verliebt zu verteidigen ein paar von
Jan Sommer war die Meisterwerk
vorausgegangen die lichtwacher als ein
Torwart Sommer kann sich bedanken und
weiß auch schon wie ich werde dem Motto
der letzten
Schweizer Schokolade für die Haustür
stehen glaube ich habe viele leistet
sich auch PSG leichtes Spiel für die
Bayern Offensive in der 61 Minute
Goretzka zu chupa-moting 1:0 in der 89
Minute der eingewechselte gnabry zum 2:0
entstand Bayern im Viertelfinale Paris
ist mit seiner Kunst am Ende
zwei Testspiele gegen Weltmeister
Dänemark für die deutschen Handballer
heute Abend und Sonntag Nachmittag dabei
wollen sie offensiv auftreten setzen auf
ihre Torgefährlichkeit
das war schon ziemlich weit sind was die
Angriffstaktiken angeht und da weiter
konstant auf der auf dem Level
weitermachen ganz gut bedienen mit ja
kurz und knackig zeigen wir alles im
Livestream Viertel von 19 ZDF
sportstudio.de danke Kristin leider
ungemütliches Wetter weiterhin Sturm
Regen und was weiß ich was da noch kommt
Einzelheiten gleich mit ostendali gegen
21:40 Uhr ordnet Christian Sievers den
Nachrichten Tag für Sie im heute journal
ein morgen an dieser Stelle Barbara
halweg schönen Dank schönen Abend und
auf bald
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter ein Sturmtief
erreicht uns und bringt wie der Name
schon sagt sehr viel Wind es zieht von
Westen auf und überquerte uns dann
Samstag nach Osten aber morgen ist es
erst einmal bei uns mit viel Wind und
teilweise auch Schneefall die kommende
Nacht bringt schon etwas Schnee nach
Norden hin diese Schneedecke wächst
etwas an ansonsten aber kommt neuer
Regen auf und die Temperaturen sinken
auf 9 bis 10 Grad nach Südwesten hin und
teilweise bis auf -2 Grad im Norden und
man sieht hier ist immer noch eine
Luftmassengrenze vorhanden einmal quer
über Deutschland morgen dann viel
Programm beim Wetter im Südwesten zieht
der Regen weiter auf und dazu gibt es
Sturmböen teilweise Wissen Flachland
ganz im Norden weiterhin auch Schneefall
zum Abend hin auch im Westen Schnee und
dann kommt auch Richtung Rhein bzw von
Westen her dann auch Wind auf teilweise
Sturmböen ebenfalls bis ins Flachland ja
und die Temperaturen dazu bis 14 Grad im
Südosten nach Norden in zwei bis drei
Grad und die nächsten Tage weiterhin
ungemütlich mit Regen und Schnee Montag
bis 18 Grad ein schöner Abend